chers amis je suis très heureuse de
m'exprimer devant vous c'est la première
fois que je le fais en tant que
porte-parole
et je remercie nicolas sarkozy de
m'avoir désigné porte-parole des
républicains mois la jeune fille née de
l'autre côté de la méditerranée jeunes
et avec tellement de spécificités qui
dérange ceux qui sont de l'autre côté de
l'échiquier politique les socialistes
alors merci d'avoir rejoint notre
famille politique merci d'avoir rejoint
les républicains parce que vous êtes les
républicains et vous avez choisi de
reprendre l'étendard de la république
celle que les socialistes donc déserté
et c'est pour cela que ça les dérange
tant que nous reprenons le flambeau et
le combat pour ses valeurs alors je
voudrais vous remercier aussi parce que
vous avez refusé refusé cet abandon de
marianne refusé que marianne soit
abandonnée en rase campagne l'un des
communautaristes des ayatollahs de la
pensée unique et de l'extrême droite
vous êtes les républicains car vous êtes
vous lever contre les détracteurs de
notre histoire politique et notre
identité nationale
vous êtes les républicains car vous avez
les valeurs de la république qui sont
intangibles la liberté l'égalité la
fraternité la laïcité que tant de
personnes aimeraient que l'on oublie et
qui est le fondement de notre de notre
organisation politique et de société
vous êtes les républicains car vous ne
croyez pas en l'assistanat vous croyez
en le mérite le travail et l'effort
ces valeurs qui rendent possible
l'ascension sociale ces valeurs qui font
que les enfants des quartiers les plus
populaires peuvent prétendre à une
certaine évolution une certaine
élévation donc là vous coûter la france
est un pays où les gens vivent les uns
avec les autres et non les uns à côté
des autres comme dans d'autres pays ces
pays qu'on prend en exemple si souvent
les états unis ou le royaume uni alors
vous êtes les républicains parce que
vous croyez en l'école publique celle
que najat vallaud belkacem et monsieur
valls aimerait tant détruire vous croyez
en sa capacité à briser les frontières
sociales par le travail par le mérite et
non par le nivellement par le bas et la
démagogie
vous êtes aussi les républicains car
vous croyez que la culture français
et allah et la richesse de sa longue
chaque jour est attaqué par la gauche
qui essayent de la détruire et enfin mes
chers amis vous êtes les républicains
car comme nous comme le général de
gaulle autrefois vous croyez en
l'exception française
alors oui vous avez fait le bon choix
vous avez fait le bon choix en
rejoignant les républicains et avec vous
nous nous battrons pour que lens est
notre langue nos racines latines
parce que notre langue c'est notre
culture c'est notre histoire
qu'importe d'où nous venons c'est notre
liberté et c'est notre universalité
alors avec vous nous nous battrons
contre la gangrène de l'assistanat sans
contrepartie et pour le travail le
mérite
l'innovation et le progrès avec vous
nous nous battrons pour que l'autorité
de l'état est encore un sens et c'est
vrai qu'avec madame taubira on peut se
demander si l'autorité a encore un sens
pour que l'autorité de l'état y encore
un sens dans ce pays et que celle ci ne
soit plus jamais remis en cause sur les
territoires de la république et avec
vous nous construirons la france de
demain sans regret pour le passé sans
remords pour le présent et avec une
confiance inébranlable pour l'avenir
alors je vous le dis encore merci
d'avoir rejoint cette grande famille
celle des républicains merci de nous
aider à sauver la république et merci de
nous aider à sauver la france